another day another senior political
figure
embroiled in the green seal scandal this
is bill crothers
while david cameron was in power he was
the civil servant
heading up government procurement
controlling 40 billion pounds a year
and he got a job advising green sill
while still in government
he held both jobs for three months with
government approval it is truly
extraordinary
that a serving a civil servant can at
the same time be
paid to work for a private sector firm
that has a clear interest
in government business we need a proper
inquiry to get to the bottom of this
not the half-hearted half inquiry that
the government have announced so far
david cameron was boris johnson's boss
but now the tables have turned
number 10 sources say the current pm is
concerned by the latest revelations
and they will be investigated by lawyer
nigel boardman's inquiry
i've given him you know pretty much
carte blanche to
ask anybody whatever he needs to to find
out
to to you know i would like it to be
done quickly
but i want him to have the maximum
possible access
before the pandemic david cameron
arranged a private drink with lex
greenstill
and matt hancock mr greenshield also met
sir simon stevens the chief executive
of the nhs and dido harding then head of
nhs improvement
who had been given a seat in the house
of lords by mr cameron
when he was prime minister helping
arrange these meetings was
david pryor the chairman of nhs england
who has also made a pier
by david cameron during the pandemic mr
cameron texted chancellor rishi sunak
multiple times he also lobbied treasury
ministers jesse norman
and john glenn plus sheridan westlake
boris johnson's senior special adviser
and mr cameron even arranged an informal
catch-up
with cabinet secretary simon case
although sources say green sill was not
discussed
the web is growing as is the pressure on
david cameron
this is central lobby at the heart of
the houses of parliament
it's where anyone can come to lobby
their mp and the verb to lobby
comes from places in parliaments like
this
campaigning persuading controlling has
always been part of political life
but problems arise when lines become
blurred
and those in government cash in on their
connections once they leave
green seals central london offices are
now empty
but the fallout continues as many as 55
000 jobs are under threat not including
a few
in politics joe pike sky news
westminster